you wrote a book harshly criticizing
Anthony fauci let me ask you the Steel
Man the case for the people who support
him what is the biggest positive thing
you think Anthony fauci did for the
world what is good that he has done for
the world especially during this
pandemic you know I don't want to
sit here and speak uncharidly by saying
the guy
um
didn't do anything but I I don't I can't
think of anything I mean if you
um if you tell me something that you
think he did you know maybe there was a
drug that got licensed while he was in
NIH that you know benefited people
that's certainly possible he was there
for 50 years
and I I in terms of his
um of his principal programs of the AIDS
programs and his covet programs and I
think that the harm that he did vastly
outweighed the you know the the benefits
do you think he believes he's doing good
for the world I don't know what he
believes in fact
in that book which is I think 250 000
words
I never try to look inside of his head I
deal with facts I deal with science oh
and every every factual assertion in
that book is
cited in swords to government databases
or peer-reviewed Publications and I and
I don't I try not to speculate about
things that I don't know about or I
can't prove and I do not I cannot tell
you what his motivations were
I mean all of us
he's done a thing a lot of things that I
think are really very very bad things
for Humanity a very uh deceptive
but we all have this on this capacity
for self-deception as I said at the
beginning of this podcast we we judge
ourselves on our intentions rather than
our actions and we all
have an almost infinite capacity to
convince ourselves
that what we're doing is is right and um
you know not everybody kind of lives and
examined life and it's examining their
motivations in the way that the world
might experience
their professions of goodness
let me ask about the difficulty of the
job he had do you think it's possible to
do that kind of job well or is it also a
fundamental flaw of the job of being the
central centralized figure that's
supposed to know scientific policy no I
think he was a genuinely bad human being
and that there are many many good people
in that department over the years
um Bernice addy is a really good example
John Anthony Morris many people whose
careers he destroyed because they were
trying to tell the truth
one after the other the greatest
scientists in the history of NIH were
run out of that organization out of that
agency
but you know people
listening to this I you know probably
you know well in hearing me say that
will think that I'm bitter or that I
I'm doctrinaire about him but you know
you should really go and read my book
and I it's hard to summarize a
you know I try to be really methodical
to not call names to just say what
happened